know what i get people all the time oh
god why are you guys talking about trump
so much i'm sick of talking about trump
because what's happening in the
republican party and trump is a big part
of it
affects all he's more powerful now it's
like obi-wan kenobi
i don't know if he's more powerful on
the bizarro side they struck him down
look what he's doing with his partner i
think he's more sinister and i think
he's more of uh
the wizard of oz but does he have powers
with wizard of oz
i guess that makes you two the lollipop
guild
[Applause]
hey all right so while our media class
obsesses over who is
and isn't wearing a mask there's
something slightly more urgent going on
that needs to be addressed
the tension in cat's one week old
marriage
[Laughter]
she's not here anyway nope
it's something called murder even if you
pull that mask
up to cover your eyes it's not gonna go
away now i get it the media only really
cares about crime when it fits their
narrative
white racist cop and innocent non-white
suspect
but if they really expect to get this
country back to normal in my definition
of normal not don lemons
we're going to need to address the
elephants in the room even axios a
liberal news site admits this
the title of their piece it's set to be
a hot
violent summer they report that in a
sample of 37 cities
over the first three months of 2021
analysis found that murders
soared 18 over the same period last year
and last year's homicides were already
up 33 percent you could do the math i
won't
these are great numbers if they're
coming from your financial advisor at
schwab
not so much coming from the law
enforcement websites
also all but three of the 66 largest
police jurisdictions
saw at least one type of violent crime
increase
and it's likely to get worse as the
weather gets hotter
so this is called a crime wave a result
of democrats releasing violent mentally
unhinged people
onto our empty streets where they prey
upon innocent victims
all while saying we need to abolish the
people tasked with stopping it
they're turning our cities into a mad
max movie where getting
shot doesn't mean your second modern
vaccine
the anti-police sentiment made it worse
after all why would cops go to any
dangerous call
if they know there's a chance they could
end up on lebron james's twitter feed
and sorry is this the result of white
supremacists
or even some angry white males well
let's ask an angry white male
[Music]
these people who want to defund the
police i don't get it then what are we
gonna do
fight crime all by ourselves i don't
think so
i like the police protecting us then i
can go back to doing what i like to do
painting bananas
typical cis white heteronormative bigot
it's weird how liberals act though when
you discuss crime it makes them more
uncomfortable than tyrus sitting in the
middle seat on a
six-hour flight they deny the data
some will even laugh when you cite the
stats worse they
act like this is an inevitable act of
nature like the season's changing or the
plunge in
cnn's ratings if only the media could
blame the crime on trump
they might actually want to do something
about it
you're watching atn all trump news
because everything else is boring by
comparison hi
i'm mika mitchell anderson lemon has the
night off and yes
mika can also be a man's name today's
top stories
a bronx man has been released without
bail after being charged with multiple
hate crimes for violently smashing
synagogue windows four synagogues to be
exact
all attacked with rocks still the
suspect was released
prompting many to say it's time to
change bail reform laws
we agree fix the bail so donald trump
goes to jail okay it's simple okay get
that monster off the street
sure he hasn't smashed synagogue windows
but he smashed our dreams
and you just know if trump hadn't been
president this man from the bronx
wouldn't have had so much picked up rage
like i do
and i get it i know the feeling i get
angry just thinking about trump
that helps meanwhile a pennsylvania man
was charged with cruelty to animals
after police say he
shot and cooked his dog if it were trump
he probably would have served it well
done with a dollop of disgusting ketchup
as you know trump is one of only three
presidents who didn't have a white house
pet
so it's clear he incited this horrific
crime he's the one who should be charged
not this pennsylvania
guy he was only reacting to trump's dog
whistle
and finally mother's day is this weekend
i would call my mom and wish her a happy
mother's day but she voted for trump
twice yes i know she brought me into
this world
took care of me fed me paid for my
education
she really is a lovely kind-hearted
person but none of that matters
she is a trump-loving monster and i hate
her with every fiber
of my being
for atn i'm mika mitchell
my favorite mika so why don't the dems
care about their dying cities
it's due to the sunk cost of their bad
ideas the same bad ideas that have
governed these cities for decades
and they care too much about holding
power over these neighborhoods
even as the victims pile up like fast
food wrappers on brian stelter's desk
so how does the media deal with this
when they finally realize the truth is
inescapable
they manipulate language instead of
violence they call it
gun violence as if the gun just got up
on two tiny
feet and shot the victim or they'll call
crime a public health crisis
as a way of removing any culpability yes
looting businesses
it's like an allergy it's just that time
of the season you know
you sneeze but i break windows and steal
watches
look we agree that when people get
murdered that impacts their health
but treating it like an outbreak of
herpes ain't gonna help anyone
there's not enough valtrex to go around
believe me
at least axios admits that the pulling
back of policing due to the drumbeat
of median activists likely contributed
to more murders and fewer
of them ever being solved and yet dear
media most of the victims are black
and ignoring that is as yellow as the
crime tape at a murder scene
by focusing on one attention-grabbing
issue bad cops at the expense
of a bigger more destructive problem a
massive crime wave
you're partly to blame it would be like
a dentist telling a meth head to floss
the four teeth he has left
out of a thousand people shot dead by
cops in 2019
nine were unarmed blacks but if you
watch the news you'd think that number
was in the hundreds
or thousands or hundreds of thousands
the press calls it an epidemic
so if that's an epidemic what do you
call the 7 400 black homicide victims
in the year prior in which 91 were
killed by other black males
don't those lives matter too even if
they never get tweeted by lebron james
and isn't that the crime that draws
police into the neighborhoods
where out of millions of interactions
you end up with a choven
look there are some bad cops but
focusing only on race and police
it's not going to make our cities safe
again or even functional
and glorifying riots in an attempt to
make cops look like rejects from police
academy 5
will result in fewer good cops and it's
most damaging to the people it
claims to help but maybe that's the
point
no more arrests no more bail no more
cities all you have left is
empty block after block if you're into
real estate it's a perfect time to buy
just don't walk alone at night and be
sure to invest in kevlar
[Applause]
let's welcome a nice guest
she's so bright we should all be wearing
sunscreen host of the lauren chen show
on youtube lauren chin
[Applause]
she's spooled more lefties than the
yankees pitching coach noble
screenwriter and tv producer gigi
labongi
he knows quips like i know whips i
prefer a cat 09 tails or a writing crop
to be honest right with comedian joe
devito
heading for cat tim she's the cheering
raider turned legal crusader
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
all right lauren is it lauren or loren
lauren lauren thank you you are canadian
now do you have crime there we do have
some crimes thankfully it's polite
enough to only happen
in montreal and toronto oh that's nice
yeah but we do
yes yes and uh seems to be growing by
the day unfortunately it's almost like
banning guns which they have been for a
long time in places like toronto
especially
uh for self-defense reasons uh it
doesn't really convince criminals that
they shouldn't shoot people
yeah yeah what do you make of what's
happening in the united states when you
see what's going on especially with the
we're seeing we're seeing a rise
in weird crime like just like aimless
dudes beating up people on the street
and the problem is with the media if the
suspects don't meet a certain criteria
it doesn't end up on their radar it is
scary especially being in a large city
right now in new york
you hear all of these reports about
these anti-asian hate crimes but i mean
those stories have kind of dropped off
since apparently they
they weren't really white attackers and
it's a little bit harder to blame them
on white supremacy now it's not
impossible
as we've seen some people try i've heard
that
yeah even if the attackers themselves
aren't white it's actually still donald
trump's fault because they were
emboldened
right by his messaging because if we
know that if there's one group that is a
huge
fan of donald trump and follows his
every word it is uh you know black males
and inner cities they just
they look to him as a thought leader
yeah you just all you have to say is
like it's the white supremacists
that are driving the non-white suspects
to attack asians yeah
then you have it all you covered every
base gg i like the name gigi
thank you yes um well you're in
california obviously you're down in
santa monica
i have a feeling you're kind of
experiencing the same thing but do you
have
are you allowed to actually talk about
it i mean uh
not in well if you are wearing a mask
perhaps especially if you're outside
in 75 degree weather wearing a mask you
can talk about it
uh if you're not wearing a mask no one
will talk to you so
that but will the criminals leave you
alone if you're not wearing a mask
like they might they might not take your
wallet if there's a chance of getting
covered
well that's true they're very well also
we need to be vegan
in order you know for them to talk to us
so
uh that gets kind of confusing you have
intersectional criminals
yes we do yeah very proud of that when
they come to mug you first they tell you
what their identity is
yes and they're pronouns right right and
then if you use the wrong pronoun they
don't want any of your belongings no
that's it they don't want the watch they
want nothing yes i know they're very
picky they're picky but they're also
polite i kind of like that about them
you know um emily you're actually uh
what are you a defense attorney there
were so many things i was expecting to
come out of your mouth
yes yes that is what i was so um
you are you're looking at this from like
somebody who defends
uh criminals what do you make of this is
is it are you saddened by it what do we
do well and i represented the government
too
i was a federal attorney for a long time
and so i feel like i have from those two
of those angles
i actually see this from a local
perspective which is how differently all
of the cities are treating this
so for example in la after they defunded
the majority of their police budget
a year later after the spike in homicide
that you referenced earlier they were
like oh just kidding
and then they infused a ton back into
the police department right sigh of
relief
and then portland was like oh no not
only are we going to strip the police of
their budget
but we are going to unanimously decline
the mayor's pleading to put two million
dollars toward it
right and then the city council said
actually we'll let you put some money
back but only to park rangers
only then because they were going to
help so meanwhile it's the bears go
ahead
literally there was a story of two park
rangers running from a guy with a knife
attacking them and then they had to call
9-1-1 to get
saved and then in seattle after they
defunded the police
the judge there who was working out you
know the doj investigates they get into
the consent decree
so everything that all the reform
everyone is talking about seattle was
undergoing that right
they unanimously again city council
decides to defund the police
the judge says what are you doing you
just set us all back three steps you
can't just
gut the budget right so for everyone
clamoring for this to be the
the result or the conclusion like it
actually helps them all over the country
you're seeing exactly why it doesn't
the crime is spiking the judges are
saying this is not how to clean up these
cities this is not the way for
meaningful reforms so if anything
that was the only reason sorry i might
be moving to l.a soon
you guys got it right eventually well
i'm moving out so you can have oh you
can have her
nice little crime swap a little crime
swap that's an interesting story it's
like wife swap but you move into
crime-ridden areas and see who gets
mugged first
i don't like that i don't like it either
actually uh joe looking for you you're a
shut-in you don't go out very often
it's true it's so you don't really
experience a lot of crime i like the
fact that we just all assume it's all
going to go away once the pandemic's
over everybody's going to be outside
and all the all the criminals are going
to go you know what now that the
pandemic stopped i'm going to go back to
my other job of not committing crime
yeah well you know i don't know if the
criminals have heard this committing
crime is actually
against the law it's not at the moment
yeah it's strange you know it's nice to
hear them say it's going to be a hot
violent summer i was hoping for a hot
girls summer but
look at what you're given um you know it
is funny
the white supremacists are having a hell
of a diversity drive aren't they
kudos to them and i i always laugh when
i hear that when people
talk about white privilege and white
supremacy and i'm like yeah that sucks
and they look at me and i'm like
oh you're including me in that because
i'm from italian-american family we've
only been white people since godfather
3. so i don't want to hear about it
[Applause]
so true hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else